más son más de 1000 habitantes y un
nivel de participación del 79 por ciento
en la primera vuelta
hay que votar es un deber hay que
votarte pero entonces a quien debemos
votar
una comuna muy movilizada pero que se
manifiesta decepcionada con la política
estamos olvidados siempre piensan en las
grandes ciudades pero en el campo hemos
perdido demasiado en 30 años que sobre
todo eso los hipermercados nos han hecho
mucho daño este habitante recuerda las
decenas de tiendas de maxim hoy
desaparecidas y es que los obstáculos de
la vida rural se acumulan
que vengan y vean por sí mismos las
dificultades que tenemos especialmente
para los que viven así les gustó el
transporte encontrar un médico es
difícil para encontrar una especialista
ahora tienes que viajar 40 kilómetros de
lo contrario no recibe tratamiento todos
los votantes de marzo seguirán acudiendo
a las urnas del domingo pero sin ninguna
esperanza real de cambio